good morning John this is one of those
videos that you write 15 times and you
still aren't happy with but here goes
after christina grimmie was murdered
i ran away from home i went camping in a
place where there was no cell service I
spent that time with my friends not
wanting to confront the reality that
someone who shared my passions and
ambitions had been killed doing what she
loved and something that I had just
spent the last two weeks of my life
doing meeting fans after a show and I
spent that time crying and feeling the
frailness of my own body in a way I
never had before understanding how easy
it is to have it all taken away that I
imagine is similar to how every police
officer in America felt after the
shootings in Dallas looking at their
family and knowing that they could be
taken away not just in the course of
doing their job but because of what
their job is a difficult job that is
usually done well and now the ones that
have options of exploring other careers
maybe they're thinking this job isn't so
worth it anymore and then I think of my
neighbors and friends and fellow
creators who have felt the frailness of
their own bodies for their whole lives
and the frailness of their children's in
their parents bodies not because of what
they do but because of the color of
their skin because of who they are
people who have lived their whole lives
under that weight because they're more
likely to be seen as a threat because
they know that any insignificant little
move that could be seen as a suspicious
action could mean the end of them I can
never fully understand that experience
but I can listen and I can be open and I
can do some research myself research
that shows that a black person being
arrested by a police officer is more
likely to be shot injured pepper sprayed
tased and beat research that shows that
they're more likely to be convicted of
crimes and get plea deals that involve
prison sentences and that shows that
once convicted they're more likely to
receive longer harsher sentences than
the average American we're promised that
the law sees all of us equally but we
know that's not true
we aren't that surprised when it's a
young white man who stands convicted of
rape that we hear from a judge about the
loss of his future and the terrible
tragedy of all of the opportunity that a
harsh sentence would bring this person
when it's a young black man convicted of
selling pot going to jail well that's
not that big of a deal
we know this we've seen this it's in the
experience of every black American I've
talked to about this and the data
consistently shows it so when we say
clubs matter we aren't just talking
about Alton sterling and falando castile
and Michael Brown and recchia Boyd and
Sandra bland and Tamir rice talking
about a fundamental and deep-seated and
destructive belief in this country that
black lives matter less belief that's
expressed at every level of society but
as a white person I could go my entire
life completely ignorant of but that
black Americans are fully aware of and
made aware of even as children to the
black members of this community thank
you for being a part of what we're doing
here and thank you for your strength and
your courage and for sharing your
experiences with us
a while back John you created a playlist
of a bunch of different creators sharing
their perspectives and experiences on
this stuff and I've added to that and
I've put it down in the description we
only get to have our one life through
which to experience the world and we're
lucky to be able to have this platform
through which we can understand other
people's experiences of the world so
everybody if you can if you have time
today just take some time to listen not
to shout or judge or fight or dismiss or
or even comment just that most
underappreciated verb in all of Internet
discourse listen it's not so bad John
I'll see you on Tuesday